empty shelves might become the new
normal for a while some stores have run
out of meat and there's no sign of when
they'll get new deliveries more than a
dozen meat processing factories have
been forced to close because of covert
19 the system requires workers standing
close together and a pattern repeated
across the country one gets sick many
others inevitably follow in neat
processing the work by its very nature
is very crowded people have to stand
there very closely together as they're
working on the line to process pieces of
meat that are going by very very quickly
the closure of factories from Missouri
to Colorado from Virginia to South
Dakota creates a real problem in the
supply chain farmers now have thousands
of animals they need to feed and house
not something they'd budgeted for we've
got to be able to to move our cattle
further along in the process and right
now there's a bottleneck in our supply
chain that's really causing a lot of
issues and some concern for our
producers Donald Trump is so concerned
about supermarkets running out of meat
that he's used an old wartime law to
keep the meat processing factories open
he's designated them as critical
infrastructure but unions are concerned
that that might mean worker safety is
put at risk
they're worried federal guidelines will
be ignored one expert says a safe
workforce means less threat to the food
supply you're looking at risks of
outbreaks if we don't practice these
infection control steps measures or on
the other hand we're looking at some
possible reduction in food supply but
not necessarily shortage so it's really
necessary to prevent the outbreak so
that the processing facilities can
continue to operate the US government
says it expects the shuttered factories
to be back up and running in days not
weeks but those in the food industry say
the impacts of dealing with the virus
will last months Allen Fisher al Jazeera
Falls Church Virginia